Ich bin Panzerkommandant beim Panzergrenadierbataillon 35 in Großmittel.
Die Aufgaben eines Panzerkommandanten ist es die Gruppe zu führen
sowie den Schützenpanzer Ulan in Gefecht zu bringen.
Ich sage meinem Fahrer wo er hinfahren muss
und erteile ggf. Befehle an die Infanterie,
was sie zu machen haben.
Ich bleibe am Schützenpanzer und halte Verbindung zur Infanterie.
Ich bin Richtschütze am Schützenpanzer Ulan.
Zu den Aufgaben gehören: das Bedienen der Kanone,
das Bedienen der Waffen-Bediengeräte und unterstützen des Kommandanten.
Das Scharfschießen ist das Highlight eines jeden Richtschützen,
da man die Feuerkraft vom Panzer das erste Mal sieht.
Nach dem Absitzen der Infanterie,
unterstützen wir sie beim vorgehen und bleiben im ständigen Funkkontakt.
Ich bin Infanterietruppenkommandant im Panzergrenadierbataillon 35.
Die Aufgabe eines Infanterietruppenkommandanten ist es, eine Gruppe zu führen
die aus 6 Personen besteht, in verbindung mit einem Schützenpanzer
Wichtig dabei ist die Verbindung zum Panzer und die Verbindung untereinander.